thank you
members welcome to rocha district
council's remote
council meeting of the 16th of february
2021
and a warm welcome especially to anybody
watching this via live stream
members i shall take item one on the
agenda apologies for absence
we have not received any apologies in
the office
do you know of any others members
no uh council mrs mason is indicating
counsellor mrs mason
uh thank you mr chairman councillor hook
why
is likely to be delayed but he will be
joining us
thank you for letting us know cows and
mrs mason
i shall take item two of the agenda
minutes of the meeting held on the 15th
of december 2020
members are you happy for me to sign in
due course of minutes of the council
held on the 15th of december i will
assume agreement
unless anyone clicks on the raise hand
icon
that is agreed members thank you agenda
item three declarations of interest are
there any declarations of interest to be
noted members
none indicated thank you members
i shall now go to agenda item 4 which is
the medium term financial strategy 2021
to 22 and to 2025
26. the leader of the council council
woodson will introduce the council's
budget and will then
hand over to portland holder for
financial services
councillor simon smith to present the
report to members
the portfolio holder for financial
services council smith
will then present the report and move
the recommendations
council horton thank you chairman
good evening members the meeting tonight
is one of the most important in the
municipal year
it is vital that we have a robust and
sustainable financial
plan for our future in order to continue
to deliver the many
important services the council provides
for residents and businesses across the
district
before i hand over to councillor simon
smith to present the report
in more detail i would just like to say
a few words
quite apart from our legal obligations
it is our duty
as all councillors across the chamber
not just the conservative administration
but to ensure we represent our residents
in a fiscally
responsible manner we recognize the
financial challenges
we all face as an authority
this last year although challenging in
so many ways
has proved what we can achieve as a
council when we work together
officers and members have quickly
adapted to new mobile
and flexible ways of working to maintain
our key services
not everything has worked immediately or
perfectly
but i think we can be proud of what we
have achieved in such a short space of
time
this work will continue over the next
year as we progress
our connect transformational programme
we've also rolled out extra support for
residents
and businesses at pace to ensure that
they have been supported through this
most difficult time
whilst not wishing to steal councillor
smith's thunder
in particular i would like to draw
members attention
to the great work done to support
businesses within the rockford district
through paying out well over 20 million
pounds of grants
for around 2 000 local businesses
during the last year this is in addition
to the rollout of extended
business rates relief for ratepayers in
the retail
leisure and hospitality sectors this has
provided a vital lifeline
to support the local economy during the
pandemic
our reopening high streets fund business
adaptation fund
already supported many businesses to
open their doors in a safe
and coded secure way when permitted to
to do so by central government
and tonight we are announcing further
additional local support
to invest in infrastructure that will
encourage more people
back to our urban centers
whilst that is all very commendable my
heart goes out to the torrid time
many businesses are having and the
adverse economic impact
that is having in our district through
this dreadful pandemic
no words are adequate enough to express
how we all feel
for you we are all longing for a time
when things can get back to life
as once we knew it members will also be
aware
that we are able to bring forward our
asset delivery program more quickly
than originally we've envisaged
including
the development of a brand new community
centre
in the heart of raleigh this will ensure
its future financial sustainability in a
way that the mill hall has not been able
to achieve
and will contribute to regenerating the
local area
as well as attracting many more groups
within our community
yes i accept that this is controversial
and i understand the emotional or
nostalgic feelings towards the current
hall
but i urge members and residents to
consider the bigger picture
of the asset delivery program across the
rockford district
if we are to be a visionary council we
have to look forward
and not back at a modest capital cost
the asset program alone will produce
cost benefits
of at least 250 000 pounds per annum
or put another way equivalent in real
terms
of a saving of nearly four percent in
council tax alone
each year which is paid by our residents
additionally there are wealth of
economic community
and improved working environment in
brand new
purpose-built offices for our
hard-working staff
the work the council achieves is
underpinned underpinned
by sound strategic financial planning
and robust financial management which
our administration will seek to continue
over the course of the next financial
year and beyond
i will now hand over to councillor smith
to set out in more detail
how our plans will achieve that
thank you chairman thank you council of
woodson council smith
thank you chairman members
i'm proud to present our
administration's medium-term financial
strategy to you tonight
we're putting forward a responsible
sustainable budget
that will help our local community to
recover and will protect
and support our residents while ensuring
essential
services continue to be delivered
it amounts to 146 pages of hard work
and is a balanced budget that the
council is legally obliged to set
the precise details the figures the
amounts and percentages
being clearly set out in the report
this budget has been prepared during a
period of unprecedented change
due to the impact of covet 19.
2021 was immensely difficult
and in 2122 this will continue
with many compounded issues but
this budget has plans for the future and
we're able to do this
because we have the financial stability
to do so
but i must dwell for a moment on what is
still in the current financial year
and i don't wish to steal any words from
the work of my fellow portfolio holders
but the bins have still been full each
week
and they've been emptied and in the last
week when there was hazardous ice on the
ground
the crews were not idle they were
gritting at vaccination centers
the grass has grown and it's been cut
housing officers have been dealing with
crisis situations
and providing essential support
the leisure centres when allowed have
been open
and the council has provided us a
support package to fusion
that's helped to protect up to 150 jobs
we've also been providing support for
businesses with over 20 million pounds
handed out
to at least two thousand businesses and
organizations
and around another 1.5 million pounds
still to go
through a combination of prudent
financial management
and some additional one-off support from
government we are projecting to contain
our cost pressures
within the available resources this year
which is a significant achievement in
the current climate
and yet again we remain a debt-free
council
yes debt free something we should all be
immensely proud of
our medium term projections anticipate a
significant decrease
in overall funding for the council over
the next five years
which alongside growth in demand for
services and inflationary increases
is expected to lead to a budget gap of
around 2 million
by 2025 26.
the overall cost pressures on our budget
in 2122 alone
total over 1.2 million
the council has worked hard to identify
cost reductions
efficiency savings and additional income
to bring this service expenditure down
to just over four hundred thousand
pounds
however there remains a gap to bridge
which we propose should be partly met
through a 2.1
increase in council tax 2.1 percent
increase in council tax
which equates to 5 pounds but not 5
pounds a week
not 5 pounds a month but yes just five
pounds a year
less than 10 pence a week for a band
d property
we must not lose sight of the fact that
the council is a business
we have costs we have wages and wage
increases to pay to our hard-working
staff
we do have some income lines that have
been impacted
and we do need to make some modest
increases
after periodic reviews our car park
charges
do need to be increased this is for the
first time in
five years but
we won't be increasing the ever popular
one-hour
tariff we will still maintain free car
parking on saturday afternoons
and on sundays and on bank holidays
as we look forward the budget provides
for a community safety initiative
of a hundred thousand pounds to help
finance investments
in safety measures across the district
the responses we received to our recent
budget survey
showed that residents said community
safety was of particular importance to
them
the residents ask and we deliver
we have a wide-ranging business support
plan
which the leader can give further
details
we have significant investment in
renewing
council assets and providing first-class
facilities for our residents
the replacement of the currently tired
and underused civic building
the mail hall is a great example the
projects as a whole
should ensure that we avoid cost
liabilities of around
250 000 pounds per annum
we have the connect project that will
allow for more
flexible and efficient working of staff
so saving residents money
and providing better services then on
the horizon we have some major contracts
coming up for renewal
in particular waste collection
although the pressures on our revenue
budget remain significant
through capital receipts and surplus
assets received in 2021
were pleased to be able to invest these
monies back into our district
this includes a new town center
regeneration fund
of 50 000 pounds to fund public space
improvements
which will attract visitors back into
our town centers
once it is safe to do so for a third
year we have
our investment in our programme of new
playground equipment
which will see new equipment for a play
space in every ward across the district
we also have resurfacing of car parks
and investment in modern ticketing
machines
that can allow for easy card payments
we're not a council that's standing
still
members i do appreciate that some
aspects of the report are not
exactly dynamic reading an appendix 3
the 2021 22 capital and
treasury management strategy included is
perhaps an example
the report has been reviewed at the
review committee and is recommended to
form council for approval tonight
but what it does go to show is the depth
the detail the hard work and
consideration
that goes into all aspects of the paper
you have before you tonight
the experience and experiences of the
last year
highlight the importance of holding
reasonable levels of reserves
to support us through times of
unexpected cost pressures
the council's total level of earmarked
reserves
remains at levels comparable to similar
local authorities
and are not considered excessive
particularly
given the climate of financial
uncertainty that is faced over the
medium term
it's proposed that the 2020 21
22 new homes bonus grant
payment is transferred to our investment
reserve
to fund capital investment in the
district pending confirmation
of a replacement scheme related to
housing growth
the council continues to maintain a
general fund balance
of around 1 million or 10 percent of its
net revenue budget
which is prudent to maintain as a
contingency for emergencies
it can't go without mention that what
i've presented before you tonight would
not have been
remotely possible without the hard work
and dedication of our officers
i would like to sincerely thank them for
that
we must not forget that despite the
appearance of business as normal
they've not been immune to the covid
crisis they've been subject to illness
and isolation and the set and the
requirement to set up
an effectively managed business from
home their work has been excellent
and it is to be commended
despite the challenges that i've
outlined tonight i'm convinced we remain
in a strong position
to meet these head-on and our
administration will continue
to advocate for financial responsibility
to ensure the sustainability
of the council over the longer term
i therefore commend this medium-term
financial strategy to the council
and propose the recommendations set out
at section 17 of the report
thank you chairman thank you councillor
smith
councillor smith do you have a second uh
chairman if i'm as leader i'm absolutely
delighted to be able to
second all the recommendations tonight
thank you
thank you councillor wooten members i
will now open the debate
and ask you to click on the raised hand
icon if you wish to speak
i will then invite you by name to unmute
your microphone and speak
it is an important item of business that
we have before us this evening
and i will ensure that everybody who
indicates they wish to speak has the
opportunity opportunity to do so
however in line with council procedure
rule 15.4
set out on page 4.11 of the constitution
i would remind members that speeches
should not exceed
five minutes thank you members
councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman
the the budget this year has been
approached in a different
vein to previous years customary
rochford district council conduct an
away day where all councils are
presented with the problems that the
officers
perceive and put forward possible
resolutions
as has been done previously the minority
groups planned
an alternative budget however mindful of
both the current conservatives leaders
statement
that he wanted to work with minority
groups
and aware of the strain that this would
create
in view of the extra administration
created for officers
working from home we withdrew this
option
and asked to be involved in the
administration's budget process
as previously despite
his statement that he wanted to work
with other groups the leader did not
take us up on this
the budget away day morphed into a
budget briefing of about 30 minutes
still if the administration ignore other
members
we should be reassured that they survey
and engage with residents
or should we the council states it is
committed to involving residents
businesses and service users in shaping
the district and the service they
receive
the response to their budget survey was
woeful
less than half a percent still the
online engagement of 5
200 nearly 6 is to be applauded
or is it unfortunately rochefort
district council have no idea as to
where these people live
so there could be responses from
scotland to scandinavia
rochefort district council have advised
they just
don't know so their commitment to
involving residents
is both empty and flawed
i question the very statement that there
is a shortfall every year
every year there's a supposed shortfall
budget on budget not actuals every year
it is closed and normally the gap left
is equivalent
to the maximum council tax rise
is this shortfall caused by central
government continuing to staff this
local authority
of funds i would like to know tonight if
this is the case
and if the shortfall has been caused by
central government
if it is not caused by central
government then how is it arisen
residents deserve to know exactly why
their council tax is being increased
my main criticism of this budget is that
as in previous years
the administration and focusing on their
preferred projects regardless of the
cost to residents
in a year when our residents have faced
exceptional hardships
and the lack of social contact
ruptured district council have initiated
no assistance other than that directed
by
and paid for by central government
indeed when shops are shut and residents
furloughed
the council's answers to helping the
high streets is to increase car parking
charges and put up council tax despite
having received funds from central
government
which should have alleviated any loss
so charge our heart press residents
another 70k
70 000 car parking to give 50 000 pounds
to the high street regeneration
couldn't make it up however
this is the council that spent around 10
000 pounds on a pet cemetery that on the
last count
still housed only one animal this is the
council
that when the country was reeling for a
pandemic rushed through its first sue
meeting
not to help residents no
but to approve a grandiose project of
over 3.4 million
so far possibly and ignore the fact that
the pandemic was altering working
practices
and the social needs that this project
was claimed to satisfied
were changing dramatically indeed
real hall which they were so eager to
demolish is now used as a vaccination
hub
with the requirements for social
distancing that are likely to be with us
long term
would indicate that a smaller community
hub is not advisable
the budget shows 341 000
as an additional income from central
government
is this being used to help hard press
residents
no to be screwed away claiming prudency
and up goes the council tax again the
council collect revenue money
places it away in a capital budget and
then says it is short of revenue
this budget does nothing to help our
residents and i will not be supporting
it
thank you thank you council mrs mason
councillor wooden
chairman thank you for that uh and as
the
initial comments from council mrs mason
were directed
towards me i would just like to point
out some facts
yes there has been a change of approach
in terms of the
budget preparation this year um
partly brought about by the
situation we find ourselves in and the
need to conduct their meetings virtually
but also because traditionally
budget away days have been held all
members have been invited and it has
only been
the conservative administration which
has actually turned up
to those budget away days
so when we got together i suppose it was
about september august september last
year thinking about how we would
organize
this year's budget i actually said
we would have finance briefings we've
actually had two
the second one i can't vouch for the
first because i don't recall exactly who
was there
but councillor wilkinson attended
councillor ionu and councillor cannell
despite invitations to all councillors
to attend
so if i am being accused of not engaging
i would actually suggest it is the
minority parties that do not want to
engage with
us it is as simple as that
because the check the leader is mistaken
he's totally mistaken counselor
um because
no we didn't turn up to the second one
if i may say i was invited to reply by
your good self
and reply uh i am well i'll come back
when you're finished
thank you mrs councillor mrs mason uh
councillors
mr councillor woodson i apologize for
the interruption
please carry on thank you chairman uh so
that is my understanding on the
on the first facts if i am mistaken i'm
more than happy to be corrected
but that is certainly my understanding
of of the position
in terms of the presentation of a budget
yes i acknowledge that some months ago
the minority parties did indicate that
it was not their intention to
uh submit a um their own version of a
budget
that is perfectly correct but within
local government circles
it is for alternative or opposition
parties
to take the opportunity if they choose
not to that's absolutely fine
the purpose of the finance
briefings was to be able to
have a discussion in the shared and
convivial environment
environment to be able to deal with
those things now turning specifically to
a few of the points i don't think i
captured all of them
i know councillor mrs mason's comments
about the increase in council tax
and her comments in relation to car
parking
the car parking increase will probably
not generate any additional income for
the authority this year
but every five years i don't think is an
unreasonable period of time
to actually look at what other
authorities are doing around us
consider their car parking charges in
their town centres
and see whether we are aligned and there
is never a good time to talk about
putting up fees and charges
but we felt that this year an adjustment
would be
correct it is an adjustment in tariff
but we've still been mindful of leaving
the popular one-hour rate
exactly the same furthermore we have
left
the uh all-day-long rate
exactly the same and that is to ensure
that employees who work in our town
centres
are not disadvantaged with those changes
over 70 000 pounds is being invested in
new car parking
machines a hundred thousand pounds is
available
for resurfacing projects so car parking
does not come at no cost
we have to manage the infrastructure
around car parking
and indeed we have our car park
attendance as well
so there is investment no one
likes putting up charges but it is the
stark reality that
as council smith mentioned earlier we
are a business
and we are in exactly the same way as
any business
confronted with the same uh increases
that businesses unfortunately face
through inflationary and other pressures
i don't think i'd possibly addressed all
of council mrs mason's points but i'm
certainly happy to be corrected
if if she tells me that i'm wrong
thank you chairman the councillor mrs
rowe
can i come back mr chairman it's
customary especially
when the leaders asked me a question and
the leaders
made a misstatement so i'd like to come
back before you invite other members as
is the common courtesy are you making a
personal statement council mrs mason i'm
making a personal statement because
there was a
personal untruth made by the leader
of the council okay um there are other
members indicating they wish to speak
but i will allow you to come back
this time only thank you i will just
mention the away days the reason that we
could often not attend was because of
the
high cost of the free meals that we
didn't think was correct
but the error that uh councillor wood
has made when he said we did not turn up
for the second um briefing
is incorrect on two counts one
i haven't received council emails since
the seventh of december
which the council is very aware of and i
have asked
to be advised of meetings that meeting
was not communicated to me
therefore i didn't have the opportunity
to attend
however when i became aware of it i
asked the acting managing director to
provide a briefing and
she did so with the section 151 officer
to the members who were not invited to
the original
meeting so i'm afraid that is incorrect
thank you thank you mrs mason uh
councillor rowe
thank you chairman um
as deputy leader of this council i too
would like to thank the opposition
members
councillors canel iono and wilkinson for
their inputs
and attendance to the financial
discussions of which every member of
this council was invited to
and i repeat every member
council smith a question please to
achieve this budget that was being put
in front of us
can you please confirm if there have
been any cuts in our services
thank you council smith can you respond
to that please
uh no there haven't there haven't been
any cuts
um there there there are
that's the plain answer that you the the
that i want to give there's no there's
been no cuts here
thank you chairman thank you simon smith
thank you councillor mrs rowe
council ward thank you
very very much uh for letting me speak
uh this evening chairman
i have to compliment um councillor smith
on on the wonderful presentation he has
made
of the budget he has been very concise
very precise but to be honest i
i i'm very very pleased that there are
members
of the opposition who did attend who did
take part
and i'm very disappointed to be
spoken to generally in a way
which shows that opposition members and
one of the main leaders of the
opposition um
has found it impossible uh to attend
through reasons that i don't frankly
understand
uh it is disappointing i have to say
because
over the past years when we've had the
budget away days
every single member has been invited to
contribute in various ways
and it's only recently that other
members have decided that
they have no wish to be part of this
council
and the process in which this council
works they want
to be part of it but don't want to be
part of it
and i think some of the criticisms that
have come out
of what we have done are totally
unwarranted actually
because they had the opportunity to
contribute they've had a full
opportunity
and they haven't taken it those that did
i
absolutely compliment in their ability
to show their true
counselor colours in as much
as that they wish to partake in the full
course of council business but that's
what i've got to say thank you channel
thank you council award councillor efti
do you still wish to speak
maybe a little bit later but i'll see
you because what i was going to say
councillor
woodson put the cross coin the uh
put it over very well sorry council
sparing please
thank you chairman just on a more
personal note
being someone who is heavily involved in
the management of a hospitality venue in
rhodey town centre
i've been at the forefront of seeing how
these venues
have struggled over the last year but i
would like to take this opportunity to
thank both
portfolio holders and particularly the
officers in the way that they have
administered the grants
that we were entitled to receive having
made the first application
there was no need and we were
subsequently approved to receive the
grant
all subsequent grants have been
forthcoming very promptly
and at the correct rate there's only
been one
further grant that we've had to apply
for which was very straightforward
which was a discretionary grant and in
the midst of all the other problems we
had to know that the money
that we were entitled to was being paid
out without any problems
any further grant applications etc was
very rewarding and i'd like to thank
them all on behalf of
not only myself but a lot of other
business owners
in the towns across the district thank
you chairman
thank you council sparing uh council
wilkinson
thank you chairman um i have attended
the
various uh financial briefings we've had
this year um
and i found them very very helpful and
um
and i thank um the section 151 officer
for the professionalism that she has and
the way that she's
presented things that the way that
someone
an idiot like me can understand which
takes some doing i can assure you
um this subject chairman is always going
to be a motive
um it's always going to cause division
and feelings and opinion
none of us want to pay any more council
tax ourselves
and i don't i also believe there's not a
single member here this evening that
wants the residents for their respective
wards to pay more either
this is not a debate about who wants
their residents to pay more
in council tax and who doesn't which i
have no doubt is how this is going to be
portrayed on social media tomorrow
i'm equally sure that many of you will
have shared in my battle of conscience
which i've undergone over the past few
months leading up to tonight
do we ensure the council is financially
stable
or do we ensure our residents are
financially stable
although in truth i would actually ask
the question is it really as simple as
that
do we have a duty to ensure the
financial stability of our council well
of course we do
for a whole host of reasons if the
council fails then we fail the residents
of this district to rely on its services
we have a duty not to waste public money
not to have to borrow where we don't
need to to be financially independent
where we can be
equally we have a duty to our residence
at a time when the covered pandemic has
not only affected
the financial stability of the council
but the financial stability of the
majority of residents and businesses
across the district
when income is down should we really be
asking residents to pay more
i personally have lost six months work
this year due to covet
and i'm sure that many others across
this district who find themselves in a
similar position
in preparation for tonight's meeting i
read the report from the section 151
officer as i'm sure
all members did there were aspects of
the report which i simply did not
understand so i've spoken with naomi
about those
and i've obtained the clarification that
i needed there were also aspects of the
report which
on a political level caused me some
concern
i took the time therefore to pick up the
phone and speak at length
with the council leader to try and get
an understanding about
the aim of this budget i note in the
report in appendix 4 it discusses the
budget survey
albeit there weren't many responses in
very simplistic terms only 15 percent of
those who
were surveyed were in favor of an
increase in car parking charges 66
against and only 14 percent in favor
council tax rise with
59 against it therefore takes some balls
to go against a survey like that
however and more importantly what i did
discover on speaking with councillor
whitten is that this budget is not an
attempt
by the council to simply replenish its
coffers it isn't an attempt to grab
as much money from the public to back to
it from the public
in an almost i'm alright jack kind of
way
what i did discover was that through
capital investments which have been
included within this budget the council
will not actually gain a single penny
in real terms in fact it's quite the
opposite
there must be a hundred thousand pounds
of new investment on a match funding
basis with parish councils for community
safety initiatives
over 170 000 pounds spent on the new
carping for
new car park infrastructure and 50 000
pounds for town centre investment
and in addition more investment into
cctv
now i think i'm right in saying chairman
that a 2.1
council tax rise accrues 158 000 pounds
or thereabouts
the simple math shows how much more is
being invested back into the community
by the council as opposed to what is
being gained by a council tax rise
if we calculate the capital investment
versus the revenue gain
from council taxes means that for every
additional one pound of council tax
raised
next year the council will invest the
equivalent of two pounds into community
safety projects and other
community-based infrastructure
i reached out to the residents in my
award as best that i can under the
current circumstances before tonight's
meeting
to get a flavor of the feeling for a
council tax rise
no one said oh yes please have uh they
said more council tax
but quite a number of them thought that
a small council tax rise
was acceptable to keep the council
services as they are
others commented that they thought the
council should make savings well
we've seen that in the last um financial
presentation that naomi gave us we saw
that so i think i'm writing saying over
700 000 pounds worth of savings made by
the council's leadership team
one lady informed me that she had
recently moved into the area last year
from romford in the havering area
and her council tax here is 33 pounds
per month less
than she was paying in romford and the
services she obtained from us are far
superior
so chairman for me this is now a
completely different concept to try to
resolve
the real question to ask ourselves is
this is it
right to ask the residents of rochard
district to pay a little more
each month in council tax and ensure
there is a decent capital investment in
the community safety for our towns
is it right to ask for an average of an
additional 10 people a week per
household to know this is going to good
use
not just going to balance the books well
for me personally that's a much easier
question to answer
i could not nor would i ever support a
budget which is simply a means of raking
money back in because our income has
dropped
not at a time when everybody is
suffering financially
equally i could not support a council
tax rise under those circumstances
either however
in my opinion the council leadership
team have done wonders to make the
financial savings they have over this
past year
in spite of covid and its related
pressures
whilst our car park revenue has fallen
for the floor the council have managed
to shorten the gap in the revenue budget
against what it was projected to be last
year when i sat through the budget
presentation last month i was honestly
honestly impressed by that chairman
it is because of those reasons that
tonight i will be supporting the
administration
and i urge all members to think about
the result of voting against
raising council taxed the result of
voting against this budget
a vote against this budget is a vote
against the commitment to financial
investment in our communities
it is a vote against financial
investments to assist the parish council
to do everything they can to support
their communities
a vote against ensuring financial
security and the good against
sorry a vote against ensuring financial
surety to the district cctv project
and is that really something you wish to
vote for because chairman i certainly do
not
thank you very much thank you councillor
wilkinson
councillor mrs belton
thank you i'm not sure i want to follow
that that was a fantastic
um some fantastic feedback just wanted
to make one point councillor sparing has
covered a lot of what i was going to say
um but regarding the the comments about
supporting business
um yet yes the money may have come via
government grants but the administration
of those grants needed to be done by
council officers
we've administered over 2 500 grant
applications during this pandemic
and still have more to go in the last
round of funding we could have gone for
a simple option and just supported the
exact same business as we did the last
time
but we listened to the feedback from the
residents about businesses that really
were needing support
such as taxi drivers such as businesses
without
premises and we we made a more diverse
and versatile set of scheme so that we
could support more businesses
so yes i accept the money may have come
from central government
however the work that's gone into that
has happened directly via this council
with staff that alternatively would have
other work they would normally be doing
thank you thank you councillor mrs
belton
councillor fd
thank you chairman um great feedback
we've had so far brilliant
i just want to say i'm really pleased to
be part of this ford thinking council
who is investing in our town centres by
the asset program
by investing in our car parks and
as well really i want to say this is
hard put together budget
and nobody wants to charge our residents
more money but
sometimes looking for the future
it's just how it is thank you
thank you councillor fd councillor canal
thank you chair i think councillor
wilkinson with some of his opening
comments
uh has covered some of my thoughts but
um having attended some of those
briefings
i would echo the um thanks to the
officers in preparing those
uh and the the detail in those
presentations it's uh
it's quite illuminating to think about
the position we're in i think
even without um reading detailed
supports residents
can guess the kind of pressures the
council would be facing
during a national pandemic it is
therefore
apologies i therefore applaud the
officers and uh the
members of the executive involved in
bringing forward a balanced budget
um with those thoughts in mind
i don't wish to go around in circles in
who attended what meetings i don't think
it's productive however i do have a
couple of questions chair
i'm not sure where best to place them so
if you wouldn't mind
affording them where you feel best
placed i would appreciate that
they are regarding um page 4.17
7.26 the green gateway trading
maintenance company i just want to
um it notes here obviously they've come
back with small profits year on year
and so i would like to ask if we are
happy with the current performance
and also if we're looking at any
opportunities to increase revenue
from this avenue thank you chair thank
you councillor canel
council smith are you able to
respond to that question i i think the
technicalities around
the um the the specific operation
of green gateway may be best answered by
uh mr hutton i don't think there's
anything too political in the
nature of the question okay thank you
councillor smith
uh mr hoffman can you respond to that
please
i can respond in general terms in the
time i mean it's really thought i don't
want to keep passing the back on and
possibly to the
directors of the company to answer but
it's it's probably not the um
the forum to do so uh um so i think
craig was
correct so council camille was correct
in saying that sir he wasn't sure if
this was actually
the correct form to to sort of seek and
answer
but i think the probably the best thing
to do is to pass the question on to the
uh
directors can answer in a timely fashion
thank you thank you uh mr houghton
uh councillor canal can i ask you
perhaps to take that point
um away and obtain uh response after
this meeting
thank you thank you mrs mcpherson do you
still wish to speak
yes please chairman sorry um for once
it's me having the technical
difficulties tonight
um just a couple of points listening to
the debate
um first of all somebody raised
um the issue of not attending the away
days due to the
extortionate costs i actually looked
into this couple of years ago
there are no lunches provided it was
coffee
that was last year this year i could see
no reason why anybody would not attend
these sessions
they were virtual everyone could attend
um
run at zero or no cost
the budget presentations they are worth
attending
you've heard that from a
non-conservative
councillors the sessions are informative
but most of all they're the opportunity
for any member
and i say that any member to feed in
their ideas for the budget
now most people here know me
if i was in the opposition i certainly
won't be quiet
i would attend every single budget to
make sure
that my voice was heard that i could
represent
my residence thank you chairman
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson
councillor hookway
thank you chairman um
firstly i'd like to say that
thank you to the officers for their hard
working
involvement in preparing the reports and
their involvement in the presentation of
those reports in the budget
um however i i do have um
one particular question in
or an issue in relation to
um the council's
ambition um in in a time
of uh unheralded uh uh difficulty for
local residents um in that
um it seems to be its main
um uh sort of like uh
ambition was to uh to be a
a a uh efficient vehicle
for the distribution of money from
central government
uh in the form of grants now i do have
to say
that it has been efficient in uh in
respect of that
with possibly one exception um in
the first round of grants to help
businesses it did have the opportunity
uh discretionary opportunity to um
to widen from the very beginning the
opportunities
of putting those grants to to businesses
that didn't have
a business address and we're not on um
the list of uh um business uh
taxpayers um and so there was an
opportunity early on as other councils
uh decided to do so to take the
opportunity i do
however um uh applaud the fact that uh
in the second round of grants that um
they did
um listen to residents and also
councillors because i brought this up at
a previous meeting that uh i hope that
uh in in the second round that they
would take this into consideration and
it's nice to be listened to
as well as uh residents will be not will
be thankful that the council
and officers listen to uh to them as
well
and so um that
obviously is a positive and i do i am
aware of some people who have started to
receive
grants from the second round however um
i would hope that uh going forward as as
we do eventually come out of this uh
this pandemic and the crisis that it's
causing
that uh the council is gonna be a bit
more ambitious a bit more
forward-thinking
and a little bit more um uh
generous uh with um
its abilities and its services to help
local residents
come out of this with
as little pain as is practical um
now it has been stated
by the portfolio for finance so that we
should all be
very grateful that this is a council
that doesn't borrow money
well you know um i don't see that
there's any
requirements for a money unless it's for
a specific
need but it then that again also shows a
lack of ambition because
in a period where their interest rates
are
absolutely historic lows and they have
been for a long period of time there
could be given um
an appropriate uh sort of
scheme the opportunity for the council
to borrow for something specific
and i think that that should not be
something
that um that should be uh uh
rejected if if um if the council was
going to be ambitious in providing or
helping
uh our local residents in future and i
think we should be a little bit more
forward-thinking thank you
thank you thank you council hawkway
council mrs belgium would you like to
come back in regards to the point raise
regards to the
business grants
yeah um initially with the first round
of discretionary funding the arg one
which i believe is what councillor hook
was referring to
we didn't have a large budget and we had
no idea that a bigger
new budget was coming shortly after so
we had to be
um we had to be cautious in the
businesses that we supported
and took the stance that businesses with
premises had bigger overheads and were
at bigger risk of failing
and that was indeed the feedback that i
was getting from businesses contacting
me for support
when the next budget was given to us
with actually much more
um freedom in how we could spend it in
terms of time scales as well
at that point we took the instant
approach to open it up to others
which included taxi drivers what people
working from home and other businesses
that had simply missed out on other
grants
beforehand thank you thank you
councillor mrs belton
uh councillor woodson thank you chairman
and um in view of comments that were
made earlier about engagement i would
like to just publicly say
that i really welcome councillor
bookway's comments
and yes it is important that all parts
of our business sector are as possible
as far as possible reflected in support
but certainly an approach was made to me
about
black taxi drivers who are registered in
london
that live in the rochford district and
the executive immediately made a
decision that we would support them
but i would like to extend a hand of
welcome to councillor bookway
to engage with councillors belton
councillors ward
and assistant director marcus hoffman
and myself if necessary in talking about
how we can effectively support
businesses and that is the way i welcome
engagement and i thoroughly look forward
to councillor hawkway
being an active part of that as we look
at
how we might spend that 50 000 pounds
that have been set aside
deliberately to support businesses in
conjunction with the chambers
authorities
as we move out of the pandemic
unfortunately we're not an
authority that can hand out you know
thousands millions of
pounds as much as we would like to that
just isn't our responsibility
but we can make a little bit of money
stretch a long way
and i invite uh councillor hawkway to
join us in that mission thank you thank
you councillor woodson
councillor milne uh yes i i'd actually
like to
thank council officers and uh councillor
smith and council wilkinson for his very
able analysis
the situation what i was going to say
was that
during the pandemic the council didn't
just hand out money they organized
volunteers they organized
all kinds of things and some of the
councils themselves were volunteers
so for that we thank them all and and
the other thing is
that being in a stable financial
environment what are we looking forward
to be doing i'm on the partnership panel
cross party economic regeneration
cross party now the whole idea
of the current executive was to improve
cross-party working and some of the
councils have stepped up to it have been
really been really useful and quite
dynamic the partnership panel
uh working with a voyage site there is a
complete public consultation
going on with that and it's just gone
out and i keep reading
posts about it's all secret oh no it
isn't
and the uh the economic the asset
um delivery uh program
the planning is still
in formation with that it's still
evolving it's evolving with input
from the residents from the councillors
and cross party
so that in itself over four years you
start looking at 2025 is probably going
to knock a million
pounds in costs out by then
because of the prudent planning at the
moment economic regeneration this is
absolutely vital because we've
taken a big hit this year we have to hit
the ground running
so with danielle ian ward and
and other councillors and and cross
party
working um that money that's coming
through and we're and talking to the
chambers of commerce and so on
looking at the e-commercialization of
the high street to try and
actually develop it and we already have
award-winning high streets in this
district
and we really want to work on that we
don't want to go backwards with it
but at the same time you're right we
have to look after the average resident
as best we can and certainly the way to
do that is to do what we're doing
and i thank you all for that
thank you councilman the councillor mr
hoy
thank you chairman i've made copious
notes i'll probably throw half of them
away
before i get to the end of it because i
just want to answer a few of the points
made as well
and to put a couple of points forward um
i mean as always i've read the budget
papers with interest and as ever
they are well prepared congratulations
naomi i think
um however well prepared doesn't mean
that i agree with the philosophy behind
the figures
i don't expect to agree with the
administration politically
nor i'm sure would they expect me to nor
do i expect them to convert instantly to
my views the moment i speak
it does not mean we are disagreeing
purposefully for the sake of it
we do so do tread due to our fundamental
beliefs
we may believe each other's each other
are wrong but i hope we do
so with this understanding and i hope
you take that as i have written it
so i'm not trying to be contentious the
past year has been difficult and the
forthcoming
one will i feel be even more so
hopefully the virus will be behind us
but our community residents and
businesses
will be starting to rebuild their lives
and financial stability
i know this has been mentioned by
council of wooden and other
um administration members as well we are
in prime
prime composition position to help in
this in fact it's in our business plan
that we should have these aims at the
forefront
of our philosophy moving forward sadly i
believe that this budget has missed an
opportunity to do so
the first paragraph of
the executive summary mentions the
five-year mtfs
the peer review of 2019 picked out the
mtfs
saying the council should deliver a
five-year mtfs
with a multi-year approach to council
tax including head room to build
capacity
in other words do a better do a
broad budget for the next five years not
just headlines
give more detail this was recognized in
the peer review action plan
but appears to have been forgotten again
when this mtfs has been prepared
we do not vote on the mtfs but i feel
that yet again this is another
opportunity missed
for the council's forward planning at a
crucial time in our history
the big issue of the year covert is
mentioned in the summary stating the
financial impact of kovit 19
has been an evolving picture throughout
20 20 21 and
this uncertainty will continue to 20 21
22
and again i think councillor wooten and
others have built on
this statement i would say however the
financial
forecast in the budget for 2021 and the
budget
for 2022 by either
20 20 21 money is a
forecast budget based on the beginning
of the year and it's now at the end of
the year
but they do not reflect any adjustment
for what has actually happened in 2021
or what we expect to happen in 2021-22
sorry about the years the budgets are
presented as though they were in normal
times and income and costs were
unchanged
parking income for instance is showing
in the budget as
one million five hundred eighty eight
thousand nine hundred pounds
exactly eighty thousand pounds more than
last year's budgeted figure
with no reflection of any reduction due
to covid
i would find it more useful and i'm sure
all members would if we were
prepared a budget based on what we were
expecting the savings we are told about
our savings against the budget last year
not what actually happened i'm aware
that this is how we've always
been always prepared the budget i just
believe it doesn't help the
understanding of our position
at this point talking about savings i'm
just going to bring in a um
something mentioned by um uh councillor
smith and also
councillor wilkinson councillor smith
said that there are there have been no
cuts in services
and councillor wilkinson quoted i can't
remember who he quoted but he said
there are seven hundred thousand sell
seven hundred thousand pounds worth of
savings
in the budget now that may well be so
but can someone please explain if that
we've made seven hundred thousand pounds
of savings why the budget has actually
gone up four hundred and seven thousand
pounds
it is four point one six percent higher
than the twenty twenty one
twenty twenty twenty one budget sorry
about the years it gets very confusing
that's just a side i don't expect
someone to have the exact answer to give
me exactly
the 700 000 pound plus the 400 i know
what the 470 is it's in the budget
but i don't know where the 700 000
pounds of savings are um
also i find it odd that arranged to be
carbon neutral by 2030 is not even
mentioned in the executive summary
in fact the only mention i found is in
the section about the cellar which
aims to be carbon neutral by 2040 with
no explanation of why
this should run through our budget and
the mtfs as part of our recovery and
investment program
i've asked our man actually managing
director if all future reports
would consider the effect on our carbon
neutral objective and i'm disappointed
that this budget does not
um as we know we have pressures in the
future with the winding budget gap
and again i kind of kind of see much in
this budget to address that problem
i.e on the mtfs i'd have thought that
we'd be looking at merging services and
roles within that with other councils as
the only way to save any substantial
amount
of money as mentioned by council
wilkinson the
2.1 percent if you take the 2.1 rising
council tax
it doesn't even match a 2 rise in rpi
for
wages for our staff um doesn't mean i
agree with it it's just a statement of
fact
um for instance a shared monitor officer
um or 151 officer or whole department
such as legal where the shared function
would make possible sensible economies
of scale and reduce the need to pay
consultants
this could be looked at within the mtfs
and again i've raised this with the
active management director and hopefully
moving forward this will be looked at
um again that
i just mentioned that raising the
council tax by 158 000 pounds
but at the same time we're doing that we
are putting to 341 000 pounds of coving
smooth
coving grant into a smoke a smoothie
grant reserve rather than use it in the
year it's meant to be used
um i've no doubt people
would argue with me about why we're
doing it and why not it's just
i just don't agree with it and that's
how it is i'm afraid
i would just like to raise a a couple of
other
points one about the um jasmine
you've already raised a number of points
how long have i been speaking then
uh chairman no um i was going to suggest
that naomi lucas responds to your
questions so far
they weren't particularly questions they
were just statements um
so you're not in a response if she wants
to respond or if another member wants to
respond that's absolutely fine and i'm
happy to
to accept that but but um
it's more of a speech than a question i
have just so
members are aware the queries i have had
on this budget i have already
asked naomi lucas about i've not left it
to this meeting to do so
okay please carry on your counselor yeah
i haven't got a lot more to say anyway
um i just want to to speak i know
councilman mcpherson raised the um
the point about the budget briefing or
the or the budget away days
um um casper mcpherson was became a
counselor the same year i did actually
in 2010
so we our knowledge of the council
should be broadly the same i would say
um i just feel that the budget away days
that we have now
are not the same as the budget away days
when i first became a member the budget
away days were much more free-flowing
um very much done on the basis you could
say what you wanted to say you wouldn't
be ridiculed for it
you wouldn't be shouted down or told
you're an idiot um
to be honest the last one i did attend
was about three or four years ago
and i came away having broadly been
castigated for daring daring to suggest
a few items
that we could do um so if you want us to
to attend i think perhaps we ought to
return to the earlier days of the budget
away days which there are a number of
members here i mean
the council hudson again would would
very well remember those as
councilmember
that there's many councils here mike
steptoe council steptoe again would
remember those days and i think they've
changed unfortunately
and i have no problem attending them if
they return to the former format
and and just so you also know the last
couple i attended i did pay for my meal
so that was easily possible to do if you
asked
um i i don't really want to take up any
more time
of the council this evening
i just want to write two more points i'm
going to raise
one is the about the budget again for
instance we've been carrying a salary
saving the budget for unfilled posts of
two hundred thousand pounds
for four years now so we're saying every
year we've saved two hundred thousand
pounds
but it's the same two hundred thousand
pounds surely um
this really arrives to two hundred fifty
with a one off fifty thousand pound for
the managing director role
are these really savings sure if he no
longer these posts they should be
deleted or made redundant
and just clean up the budget a bit um
i'm just afraid i can't support this
budget and winning will vote against
i do hope next year will be a better
year for all of us
regardless and that we can return to the
budget away days
which i've just mentioned from when i
first joined the council
with all views being heard and respected
and where we can have a budget of the
whole council on which we agree
i do remember those days and i and i
think you if we look at the voting
record you might even find i might have
voted for some of those budgets
thank you that's all i have to say
tonight thank you um
councillor high i take it then that you
don't uh
wish to have a a a response to those
points yes
i'm happy for a response but i don't
expect a response
this just came up the 700 000 came up
tonight from council wilkinson
i don't expect a response tonight but if
someone wants to to
to say something about it i've got no
problem okay can i come back on a just a
point of clarification
then just regarding that is that
possible
uh is it quick councillor wilkinson is
to do with exactly what council hoists
just asked yes
to do with that just just very very
quickly so that in case somebody is
going to answer
the 700 000 pounds i'm referring to was
the
the figure that naomi mentioned at the
budget presentation that the savings
that had been made by the leadership
team
um i may have misquoted the figure
that's what i'm referring to just for
clarification thank you chairman
so if i come back yes i do understand
where the figure came from then
and also just for clarity i did attend a
separate budget
briefing which i was unable to attend i
did receive the invite but i couldn't
make the evening
i do understand that councillor mrs
mason councillor
newport did not receive the invitation
at all because of email issues
um could i ask naomi lucas please to
respond
on some of those points
thank you for inviting me to speak chat
um yeah i i will just pick up a couple
of the points that council roy's raised
if that's okay
um i think firstly just to point out
that the vacancy um
factor isn't specifically attributed to
all two particular vacant posts it's
just a recognition that at any point in
time
there will always be um a certain number
of posts vacant and i think if we
um philly budget for those every year we
will always deliver a surplus so
it's a recognition that at any point in
time some posts are likely to be
vacant and and that's our best estimate
of of the saving that we would deliver
year on year so it it's not a case of
kind of not tidying up our budgets
as such so i hope that kind of clarifies
that point
um the second point around the specific
um figures in the budget i would just
draw members attention to
um 7.5 um which sets out
the key pressures and growth items that
the council has been facing this year
alongside the efficiencies and incomes
that we've um
delivered to help offset those um
pressures
um so i would also just point
you to paragraph um
4.6 of the executive summary um which
sets out that there have been budget
pressures of over 1.2 million
this year which would have been
identified um
those are being offset by savings and
efficiencies and income
of just over 850 000 pounds and i think
that figures just moved on slightly to
when we did the budget briefing
and then that leaves obviously a net gap
which as members have alluded to earlier
we are partly
meeting through um some small additional
funding from government which is one off
in nature with the residual gap to be
met through council tax
so yeah the full extent of the pressures
is quite extensive
um and obviously includes items such as
our staffing growth and our contract
pressures and also specific things that
we're facing this year
and as a result of covered for example
materials recycling
um facility income that we get in
um the third point i would just like to
respond on is is one that i think
i think counselor who might have
actually answered in his own statement
and he questioned why we haven't
adjusted budgets
to reflect the impact of cobit this year
um but then he also stated that we have
put
our kobe grant into reserves to help
manage those pressures
and the reason we have not kind of
specifically adjusted individual budget
lines for those is because
um obviously it's very difficult to
predict the exact nature of those
pressures and the extent of those so
in some extent to some extent it would
be quite an arbitrary judgment about
whether
certain lines would be kind of reduced
by five percent or ten percent
so we've taken the decision that it's
prudent to put um
the additional monies we've got from
government um in relation to code into
reserve
and obviously we will draw on those as
required to balance the budget over the
course of the next
financial year so i hope that kind of
provides some clarity on the way
um the approach that we take into budget
setting this year thank you
so if i may come back on that chairman
just very very quickly
um on the last point that naomi lucas
raised i'm very well aware of
the reasoning behind it i'm just stating
i disagree with it
that's all it's just a different point
of view which is what i was trying to
say at the beginning of what i've said
we will have different views on things
but please understand to everybody that
we have we have reasons for those
beliefs and we're not doing it on
purpose
thank you thank you council and
counselor newport
thank you chairman um i need to put my
hand down
yeah i think uh it goes without saying
so thank you to naomi
for all her hard work but also thank you
to
um other officers particularly um marcus
hotten
and luisa moss i know i've been working
very hard on
you know waste collections and
homelessness so i'd just like to
say a personal thank you to them um
i guess really it's looking at the
budget and
speaking to residents as i know other
counselors have
i it's not it's not just about my own
feelings on this budget but also
relaying the feelings of those people
that i'm elected to represent
so um in 2020
which we know was undoubtedly tough on
the finances of the council
it's been very hard on the finances of
many residents
and as we begin 2021 unfortunately
find many more residents and businesses
continue to
experience anguish over their own
financial
uncertainty and i think this is uh my
main point here that the way i look at
it is i think
councillor wilkinson said you know do we
prioritize the council
or the community and you know i may have
a different slant on this but
as a as a local authority we have that
choice and we can either support the
community
or ignore them it's now the time that
the council should be doing
everything within its power to support
that those that
live work and invest in the district the
budget doesn't
give me that confidence that it's a
priority
as our high street struggle to recover
after many many months of lockdown
different working practices and extra
costs and uncertainty
due to the pandemic the councils
responded by proposing an increasing
parking charges
and spending seventy one and a half
thousand pounds on paying display
machines
now i don't know looking at the budget
whether that is
you know i'm my suspicious mind is
whether it's to curb
the transfer of already paid for parking
tickets
to increase revenue or is it that
there's a need to replace those
parking uh the pay and display machines
the 50 000 pound that's been put in for
a town center regeneration fund
i just don't think it goes far enough i
i think
our towns are going to need more across
three towns i believe that was
uh 50 000 pounds i just don't see where
that's going to get us and i don't think
and you'll know my feelings really on
this is that the work hasn't been done
how can we save 50 000 pounds the work's
not been done
to establish what's needed but i do
think it's gonna be more
than fifty thousand the support that our
businesses have received
other than through the grant by central
government which has already been said
by a number of councillors it's
been very disappointing many businesses
have
simply been left out in the cold by the
government and the council
the discretionary grants they fail to
include many small business owners and
i've heard from
many business owners who haven't
received a penny
um from the discretionary grants
a proposed council tax rise this year
whilst
many residents budgets are going to be
stretched further by reduction in
working hours
and their incomes and redundancies it's
going to be very difficult to support
an increase in our council tax i can
accept there's been a downturn in the
revenue
but while the council proceeds with
asset strategy project
and the huge capital expenditure that it
brings of over 3.4 million
i simply can't support asking residents
to pay more
just going back to the looking at the
report
i can only surmise that the budget
consultation
failed to reach the acceptable number of
our residents
the council as i've said previously in
in many meetings where we've had
consultations
is the council really does need to
invest in that in that area for the
future
and take account of those results thank
you chairman
thank you thank you chairman point of
order please
could i just ask councillor newport uh
to clarify a small element of what he
said
was he suggesting that the swapping or
exchanging
of parking tickets was acceptable please
thank you
oh for you chairman if i may to
councillor smith
um the swapping of these
are you referring to my mention of the
seventy one and a half thousand pounds
on paying display machines counsellor
smith
i i found oh are you saying about the
swapping of the transferring of tickets
between
car park users yes is that what you're
asking me
yes i think you know um that that
does occur um and it's done in a
friendly
manner in our community and
yeah maybe it's it you know
i think that maybe
you know where it's uh you know people
have paid an hour and there's half an
hour left
i don't see that that that hurts they've
paid for the car parking space
chairman i i i must just take issue here
the
car parking ticket on it says it is
clearly
not transferable it clearly says in the
terms and conditions
that uh doing so is not allowed and
would be subject to a penalty fair
and effectively the pr the the
the um action of exchanging
um car parking tickets or suggesting
that it is acceptable
is effectively defrauding the council of
a proper income
and i i would seek further advice on
that thank you
thanks thank you council smith and thank
you council newport
um council stanley please
thank you gentlemen um firstly it's
it's apparent that there is some some
sort of
uh objections or
whatever you'd like to call it between
the minority and the majority that run
the council
um it's it's very annoying to hear this
in in as much as
you know we're all counsellors and we
should all be
asked and and brought together in a
friendly manner it doesn't seem as
though it's going down too well tonight
that's to my way of looking at things
and let's talk about the budget
because we're not talking about
individuals we're talking about the
budget
and and and the budget means an awful
lot to people
out there um i've got
residents that have only had 80 percent
of their
income from the from from
furlough and and and some of my
residents haven't had any money at all
for some time
and here we are putting up the council
tax yet again
um with the i do find that's a little
bit
offish to be perfectly honest we've got
reserves
so we could perhaps and this is only my
thoughts
is that with having such a big amount in
reserves
no matter where they are it's still
money that the residents have paid to
the council
perhaps it could be a bit more lenient
towards those people that have lost
their jobs as well
how many shops in the high street have
lost
are not
members it would have members it would
appear that we have lost
council stanley yeah yeah i'm connected
to you for a moment
council stanley carrier it did it did
yes you're quite right
i'm reconnected now um yes as i was
saying there are there are many shops in
the high street
that uh have closed up due to the fact
that uh
they can't trade any longer under these
conditions
and and the people that work there
they're no longer got a job
but they've still got to find this tax
um
you know we've got to think about our
residents
who haven't got a job who have only got
one wage coming in
and so on on another important issue
and and it's already been spoken about
the the the car parking
again how many cars are in the car park
at the moment
if we was trading if every shop was open
and trading
that car park would be full at the
moment it's empty
well not quite empty but you get my
drift
there's not many in there so we've got
to look at things
in the right manner and we don't we i
can't say i've got a crystal ball that
looks into the future
i don't know what when we're going to
get back to trading i don't know how
it's going to be
and and those of us that can see it well
you've got a crystal ball and i haven't
because i can't see that at the moment
everybody's in lockdown and and we and
you know we've got to hold hold back and
hold our aussies
because it's no good whipping the horses
into a gallon because we
when they can't get there so my view is
that
the the the budget is is
really i know we had to make a budget
i realized that and i do understand
where we go where we're going
but i do think we could be a little bit
more lenient and
there are other aspects in the budget
where
and i don't know if councillor smith
could answer this in the budget that
footpaths what footpaths are we talking
about
where we're going to spend 15k because i
don't think 15k is going to be
anywhere near what he's what he's put
proposed
um in the wire footpaths so
and there are small items where they're
running without any offices
that everyone is working from home there
must be a colossal saving there
absolutely colossal i don't think the
heating's on on the civic suite
in fact i don't even think the heating's
on on them on the mill but it might be
now because we're using it
for covid but you know
that there must be a colossal saving
for this past year i do appreciate
that what the officers have been working
with with the government guidelines on
how much they've got to do um
it's something which the government have
asked all councils to do
we're not just the only ones and
that's where that comes into line i'm
sure that
they they have done a colossal job and
and i absolutely admire i put my hands
up to them
they they are very good in what they're
doing and
and i think they've done an excellent
job
in relation to the person that come out
of romford
and said that our council taxi is less
than what he is at romford
romford is actually but well yeah in the
london area
uh more so um and so you'd expect higher
prices
from romford one of all the chairman
please we've
gone twice now for two members well over
the five minutes
yeah he was well over or somebody else
was well over before counter stanley
counter stanley
just finished chairman please i just
want to finish this sentence
very quickly encounter stanley please
you're nearly coming up to your five
minutes
yes they i i'm quite aware yes but our
head was cut off
anyway um yeah what was i saying um
yeah in relation to the the prices of
homes in romford and the prices of homes
in in raleigh are
somewhat a lot bit lot different uh you
can get more for you
and get more for your buck or whatever
you're paying for
it will cost you a little bit more um
yeah
as i said uh there's several aspects
that need to be certain
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for letting me say a few words
thank you members um a number of
counters
are indicating they wish to speak they
have already spoken
um i'm going to allow three more
speakers
five minutes each um and then we'll go
to the vote
uh councillor webb please thank you
chairman
i'd welcome this balanced budget and i'd
like to thank officers
and councillor simon smith for all their
hard work and dedication to get us to
this point
this budget has given us much to
celebrate in particular i welcome the
hundred thousand pounds
investment in our community safety works
for new capital projects
and i look forward to working with town
and parish councils on these projects in
the year ahead
it should be noted that we will be
seeking match funding for this work
which will ensure that this money goes
further
as well i'd also like to reflect on the
earlier comments have been made
we remain a debt free council
we've been able to help over 2 000 of
our businesses in the past year
in addition to that our leisure centers
will be open again
our swimming pool will be there for our
residents our children will be able to
learn to swim
unlike in a number of other districts
where their swimming pools have been
closed
hours have remained open in addition to
that we have a 50 000 pound investment
in our town centers
that is an amazing achievement for a
relatively small local authority
and it shows our commitment to local
business and to our local town centers
so in just in summary i once again want
to thank
the officers and councillor simon smith
for delivering
once again a balanced budget an
excellent budget but also a forward
thinking budget with some new
initiatives
and some new in some new investment in
our capital infrastructure projects
thank you chairman thank you council
webb council wilson
thank you chairman um really i've i've
got
some questions for um council smith
really um
the it's very reassuring that there are
no council services that are going to be
cut
um but my question really is
are we sure that um we will have the
same levels of service that we'll be
able to provide
with this budget um my second question
really relates to
on on page 4.12 there's a table
and we've got the staffing vacancy
factor
and this is only a suggestion it's you
know take it for what it's worth
but if we are always carrying these
levels of vacancy
should we just not take them out
for the future um
my third one actually is is for roman
councilwoman leader
and i fully support maintaining our
infrastructure the worst thing you can
do
is not to put money into things and
watch them slowly decay over time
and but it's a specific question really
to
car parks that i understand we're going
to upgrade them
but i would expect that either to be a
spend to save so in other words we're
going to spend some money that's going
to
reduce council costs or that's going to
reduce
that sorry that it's going to generate
some income and i can't really see how
that's going to happen from this
thank you chairman
thank you thank you councillor wilson i
think your second question has already
been answered by
naomi lucas if i'm correct um
perhaps i can ask to counselor fd to
come back in respect of the car park in
question
thank you chairman um where you're
talking you're talking about the
investment in the machines
are you not talking about the
resurfacing yes so the investment in the
machines
machines at the moment are always
breaking down they don't work so there's
lost income
when they're not working also it will
as was mentioned earlier it should stop
ticket transfers
but other than that we just need to keep
we
as you said we need to invest in
machinery that actually works and does a
good job for our residents
it was it was their resurfacing as well
cancer
yeah the resurfacing um
well we need to keep as you said we need
to keep our infrastructure
modern and uh usable we don't want
people in there
damaging their cars we need to it's a i
think it's a rolling plan of resurfacing
we do
car parks every so many years
to just make sure they're up to standard
which is acceptable for
all users so i don't really i think
there's i don't really think there's a
money-making scheme in that that's just
for infrastructure
and resurfacing thank you chairman sorry
if i may
the the first part of my question was um
for council smith which was that we're
not getting rid of any services but
will we maintain the same level i've not
forgotten that question council
wilson council smith would you uh
respond to that please
yes we we we absolutely do believe that
our service levels will not be reduced
in
in any form and the budget provides us
with the
flexibility through our uh financial
management to be able to adjust service
levels to
to demand as appropriate and just
building on the reply that was given
with regard to the
vacancy factor we must fully cost um
or all of the jobs at the start of the
year i won't say it's crystal ball
gazing but we do have to accept
that there will be some flux of staff
leaving new staff starting staff
coming and going on different pa pay
rates maternities
uh the time it takes to
recruit new staff periods of notice and
so on
so it is right that we do attempt to
quantify that
we've quantified it at the same sort of
level
most years um but but it is a movable
feast and it is a
i do believe it is appropriate that it's
in there each year thank you
thank you kel mr chairman can i make a
point of order
so if you wish to mrs mason
thank you on i believe three occasions
now
members have raised questions and you as
the chair
have directed them to administration
members to answer
the rules of debate state quite clearly
that should not happen
um and i'd ask you not to do that again
thank you
council mrs mason direct questions to
whoever i think is best
to give them i'm sorry the rules of
debate you need to look up the
constitution mr chairman i'm trying to
be
as polite as i can in the circumstances
but in each occasion
in one occasion when i made you
disallowed me to come back
but then you allowed councillor wooden
to speak over me you've gone back to him
on occasion
you directed an opposition this is meant
to be a members debate
and you said quite clearly you would
allow members to speak once
but you're not you're choosing people
who you want
to speak and i'm sorry the constitution
doesn't allow that
so it is a point of order i i'm not i
don't want
anything to happen i just want it noted
and perhaps
not repeated counselor mrs mason as i
said at the beginning
i allow people to speak in the order
they wish to speak
and you think he would allow each person
to speak once and
and you haven't you've been directing
questions
to um the administration but i'm sorry
if this isn't a debate it is a point of
order and i'd like it looked in and
i accept that obviously you're not
accepting what i'm saying
so perhaps you can look at it after the
meeting i don't want to
be unpleasant about this i'm just trying
to point out that that is not the normal
way of a debate and i'm sure the
officers can help you with that
thank you thank you councillor mrs mason
but
if questions are asked of certain
members they're entitled to give a
give a response i shall leave it there
the last
speaker who didn't allow me to respond
when untrue allegations were made about
me so i i think
i'm not happy with the
um fairness of the situation but and i'm
trying not to say anymore but
i don't want that this is a debate about
the budget i'd rather we stayed with the
debate about the budget
i'm just pointing out that that i agree
this is not correct council excuse me
sorry chairman i can't that's the point
point of clarification
so i can't let this go but counselor mrs
mates was the first to speak
she spoke it was all quiet when she
spoke counselor
wooden was brought in to answer her
questions and she interrupted him he did
not interrupt her
so i'm sorry but that's a clarification
that he's wrong
yes but i wasn't allowed to come back i
don't know this isn't mrs mason we're
going to leave it there thank you very
much
i'm going to allow one more member to
speak
and that will be council williams after
that we shall go to the vote
council williams yes thank you chairman
thank you very much
most interesting debate so far and i
think a very very successful budget if
i'm honest um
recently i've i've been um along with
other counsellors i've been volunteering
at a local surgery
helping marshalling for the um for the
for the kobe vaccinations
i've met many of our many of our
residents i'm talking in the hundreds
here
i've spoken to many of them very
interesting and it's been a privilege to
speak to them
i have not had one complaint about the
services that we have supplied so far
in fact we have not just
met the demands put on our services we
have surpassed them many times
um i would just like to say thank you
very much that i would like to put this
on
on on record that i'd like to thank all
of our contractors the contractor staff
our ads the executives of this council
and all members of this council
thank you very much and it's been an
absolute pleasure and a privilege
to be part of the administration thank
you thank you councillor wilson
williams um members i said before that's
the last
member to speak may i sum up chairman
sorry they are some up prior to the vote
of course sorry counselor simon smith
please
thank you chairman uh i i would like to
thank uh
members for the fallen uh and
wide-ranging
the debate that we've had uh i i think
we've had
a number of uh state statements made and
um as as i think council lahoy said
there are some aspects to the budget
that people agree with some aspects
that they don't but this administration
has put forward a balanced budget
that we are obliged to do so it is a
budget that is forward thinking
and shows initiative and innovation
our community safety
initiative with the potential for
investment in cctv
being a prime example of that
we've had many thanks go to or
be put forward towards our offices and
as mentioned
i do uh re reiterate that
but please members remember that this is
a
conservative administration and this
conservative administration
is putting forward the budget that is
before you tonight
i think that we have had um a number of
questions that have
that have been answered one point that
was made
was that residents needed to be
consulted more
well the the figure that was mentioned
of 5
200 views of the um the the
youtube clip or although i think
councillor mason suggested some of them
might have come from
from scandinavia i think it is a
tremendous figure
regardless and sometimes when people
listen but then choose not to comment
it does indicate a degree of
satisfaction
or acceptance with what is being
proposed
as councillor wilkinson mentioned you
won't find many people that will
just straightforward come out and say
yes i want the council tax to be raised
yes i
i want car parking charges to be raised
but when you explain that the council
tax is going up
to provide a heart a good level of
service
that you remind people that car parking
charges
have not been raised for five years and
we are doing what we can within that
charging structure
such as the all-day charge and the
one-hour charge to maintain the degree
of stability
the majority of people do accept
so chairman i i am more than happy with
the
proposal that we have put forward
tonight given the challenge
of the circumstances that we found
ourselves in last year
and the challenge of the circumstances
not of our doing that we will face
next year i believe that our
administration our financial
administration
has put us in a position to put forward
a budget
which is as acceptable as can be given
the circumstances
and in fact i think it's something that
we should be proud of
so um thank you very much chairman and
i'm happy to go to the vote
thank you council smith
um members we have 13 recommendations
moved by council smith and seconded by
council wooden
the set out of paragraph 17.1 on pages
4.27
and 4.28 of the report
recommendations 4 9 10 11
and 13 are for noting
are these noted members i will assume
your agreement
unless you raise your raised hand icon
noted
this is christine mason yeah
chairman you're on mute sorry are there
a word you're saying chairman
thank you thank you councillor stanley
members recommendation six relating to
council mrs mason you wish to speak yes
sorry
mr chairman but could you read those
numbers out again that you were
asking to be noted i can
their recommendations 4 9 10
11 and 13. and they've all been noted
well they weren't because i raised my
hand and you didn't come to me
um you didn't ask me um why you said
raise your hand
if you didn't want them noted i raised
my hand and
surprise surprise i was ignored um mr
chairman
i've got no problem with four well i
have been reporting before but
number 10 i would like it noted
um it says we want to note it
is robust i object to the word robust
and therefore i would know um like my
objection to that
noted but no problem with the report
being noted but to say that it's robust
i is is subjective and not what the
report
um and noting should be about no noting
should be objective
not subjective so i'm afraid i have to
disagree with item 10.
council mrs mason that will be noted
thank you
thank you members recommendation
six relating to a proposed increase in
council tax must be determined by a
recorded vote
i would suggest retake we take the
recorded vote on this now
when i call your name can you please
indicate whether you are voting for or
against the motion or if you wish to
abstain
counsellor mrs bolton
for the motion thank you thank you
councillor burton
for councillor mrs butcher
all the motion thank you councillor
canel
for the motion chair thank you counselor
mr carter
or a motion chairman counselor mrs
carter
thank you chair are we recording at all
please
record it this is a recorded vote yes
yes thank you it wasn't clear at the
beginning um yes i like a recorded vote
um i do not support this budget and i am
against
your vote mr mr councillor mrs carter
myself
for councillor fd
for the motion thank you chairman
councillor eves
council mrs gooding for the motion
thank you chair council hazelwood
for the motion council hookway
thanks chairman
what was your vote councilway since
um i'm voting against chairman
councillor against chairman
councillor hudson all the motion
thank you councillor ionu all the motion
council lucas gill all the motion
chairman
councillor mrs lumley or
councillor mrs mason against the motion
council mrs mcpherson for the motion
thank you chair ellis and merrick
for councilman
for the motion chairman council newport
against councillor pavlin
ford's motion thank you chairman
councillor mrs rowe
thank you clement iv councillor mrs shaw
thank you chairman for the motion
counselor mr shaw
for the motion council smith for
council sparing or council stanley
against council steptoe
the council award for
council web for councillor mrs weston
four chairman councillor wilkinson
four chairman councillor williams
thank you chairman for thank you council
wilson
against chairman again council wooden
for chairman thank you members
councillor eves can you clarify the way
you wish to vote please
thank you again thank you no no no no no
abstain sorry abstain yes
yes thank you councillors
members that has been passed there were
29 4
seven against on one abstention
27 votes in all thank you
37 chairman 37 i think that should be
37 thank you 37 my apologies
chairman you're on mute again
members we are now left with
recommendations 1
2 3 5 7 8 and 12. are you happy
to for these to be voted all together i
will assume your agreement unless
anyone clicks on a raised hand icon
some which are a matter of fact so five
for instance as a matter of fact i'm
sure the calculations are correct
but i don't agree or agree with other
ones it's just the way
the way um that wasn't
past that vote so we will take the
recommendations
um individually
oh my computer's gone
i shall now take recommendation one
thank you the net revenue budget
requirement be set at 7.722 million for
2021
stroke 22 as pub as per paragraph 7.20
if anybody wishes to have a recorded
vote
would they please indicate by their
raised hand icon
there will not be a good cut there will
not be recorded vote members
could i ask those who wish to vote for
uh recommendation
can i ask those who wish to vote for
recommendation one to indicate by their
raised hand icon please
chair its councillor lauren shot i can't
raise the hand but i
i'm four sorry thank you council laureen
shaw we will note that
uh uh chairman councillor george irano
i can't access the raised hand either
but i would like to
vote for thank you councillor ionu we
will note that
chancellor carter chairman i i can't get
raised hand and i'd vote for
thank you councilman carter
i believe council hazelwood has also got
a raised
a physical hand
who was that capital ward councillor
hazelwood
hazelwood council can you raise your
hand
okay thank you council award
is
um
okay
members could you now lower your raised
hands please
and those members who wish to okay
can those members who wish to vote
against indicate by raise ham please
i'm standing yeah that's that's done
that's
if you could members if you could lower
your raised hand now
please mr chairman councillor mrs carter
connection's dropped she's going to be
on the phone so perhaps someone could
ask her
on the phone
i thought she was in there her
connections dropped apparently
i've just come back in but i can't
actually put my hand up nothing
on this side of things that's happening
i'm afraid so
um i've been trying to get a hold of
somebody there to speak
my hand's not going up on any of the uh
voting i'm afraid
council mrs carter do you wish to vote
against
yes on that one please yeah we will note
that thing
members recommendation one has been
approved 30 votes
for seven against
no abstentions
um
members in view of the time i would like
to remove a motion without notice
according to council procedure rule 14 n
to extend this meeting
beyond the two and a half hours for as
long as practical
in order to complete the business can i
have a second to please
i think i'll second that for you
chairman councillor weston
thank you councillor weston um
councillors if you're not able to
use the electronic race handers please
unmute your microphone and let me know i
will then check you separately
if any would like a a recorded vote to
be taken please
click on the raised hand icon
it will not be a recorded vote could i
ask everybody in favor of chairman
on a personal statement could i just
point out that i've been on the screen
for two hours
during the day i've been on a screen for
around seven
hours i do allow myself breaks after an
hour
i'm quite kind to myself so this would
make nine hours i've been looking at a
screen today
i really could do with a break i've now
got severe headache
at the moment and i i am not functioning
properly you might say i never function
properly but
i really am struggling at the moment
counselor mr hoy if you allow me to
continue i was just going to announce
um a break all right thank you very much
german
there will not be a recorded vote those
in favor of the proposition please
indicate by
raise hand icon
chairman counselor george iwano
i'll be in favor of the motion thank you
councillor ionu
okay i'm just looking to see
so we've got um those that haven't voted
on look
hazelwood can we have your vote please
council hazelwood can hear me
okay
my speaker's going on and off
sorry are you voting in favor
council haven yeah thank you
mr chairman i'm not sure what's
happening with the screen it keeps
flashing and it's making me feel
disorientated i'm not sure what's
happening
counselor mrs mason there's no flashing
that is ending i can see
it keeps changing from one screen to the
other
i think it must be your end then mrs mr
council mrs mason
no i'm getting exactly the same as well
sure might i make a suggestion when
someone raises their hand it changes the
order
of the video boxes so if people make
their screens smaller
if the video boxes are disturbing them
thank you councillor
thank you
could you please now put your hand icon
down please
members
to vote against the motion please
indicate by race hand icon
members if you could uh put put your
race hand icon down please
and those that wish to abstain
all i'm doing is clicking on the raised
hand darkness okay that is approved and
that motion has been approved
you went on to speak um members
that motion has been passed and i shall
adjourn the meeting for five minutes for
a comfort break
please come back to us in five minutes
thank you
yes
yes
um
can someone advise me what's happening
because i was actually
kicked out for some reason i've got back
in but i don't know what happened with
the last vote
or what's happened
council mrs mason the vote was agreed
we're currently in uh recess for five
minutes for a comfort break
i'm waiting for everybody else to come
back so we can restart the meeting
okay thank you mr chairman i didn't
manage to vote on the last
last vote i assumed you realized that i
wasn't there
thank you
so is it item 3 next
um i shall announce that once
everybody's back counts and mrs mason
thank you for the help
six
members thank you for coming back i
think we're still waiting for one or two
members but i shall make a start
members in view of the time i seek your
agreement
um to take recommendations
two three five two
three five seven and twelve
in their entirety in one block
um i shall read them out you've all got
them on your
agenda but i shall read them out item
the recommendation 12 is that the
capital program for 2021
22 set out as section 9 and the proposed
methods of financing and capital
expenditure
be approved recommendation three
is that the assistant director resources
be authorized to adjust capital project
budgets
in 2021 stroke 22
after the 2020 stroke 21 accounts are
closed and the amounts
of slippage and budget carry forward
required are confirmed
five that the 2021 stroke 22 band d
equivalent tech base for the purpose of
determining the council tax charge be
agreed
as thirty two thousand and fifty one
point nine properties
recommendation seven that the schedule
of fees and charges for 2021 stroke
22 set out an appendix to be approved
and recommendation 12 is that the
capital and treasury management strategy
for 2021 stroke 22
has set out in appendix 3 including the
2021
stroke 22 potential indicators be agreed
members if you agreed to
take them on block would you please
indicate by the rice
raised hand icon
chairman i would like to take it unlock
counselor george
can i have your votes please
abstain chairman agree
thank you
abstain chairman councillor stanley
um
um
thank you
is
members thank you for your votes we will
take those
items on block
mr chairman as a point of order i didn't
have my hand up
um because
i had my hand up earlier because i
wanted to advise you that
uh counselor michael hoy has had to
leave
because he's had trouble with his eyes
um
due to the screen time so he's had to
leave the
meeting so then when it when
it flashed i managed to i took my hand
down because i don't agree to it going
on block okay but that that that has
been passed to councillor uh
mrs mason then if we
unfortunately i want to vote different
ways on different things so if you're
denying me that then i'm going to leave
the meeting because i'm just fed up with
the lack of democracy okay
it shouldn't be a majority to take
something on block
it should be unanimous but if you're
saying it's a majority
then why didn't you do it in the first
place i really can't understand the
inconsistencies here
i was going to ask you to take number 12
separately
i want to board a chairman
what you've ordered chairman
she's right because she's the one
i've established that there was a timing
issue with regards to the raising of
your hand
um and we will now take the votes
individually
she's going to absolutely have to do
item 12 separately if we can do all the
others on block
there's only one she wants to do
separately i think in fairness it would
be better to take them separately
it saves a confused it's very difficult
because
i'll explain the problem i had my out
which was ignored to
advise of counselor hoyt um having to
leave the meeting that then
because we were asked to put our hands
up it just flashes everywhere and
you just i just can't move the cursor
quick enough so it's really
disorientating and it's very difficult
to cope with this to be honest
um exceptionally difficult but
it the obviously they've changed the
range hands mechanism and it causes a
problem i i know counselor canals
explain why
it doesn't make it easier mrs mason we
will now
take um a recommendation
number two okay thank you
that is the capital program for 2021
stroke 22
set out at section 9 and the proposed
methods of financing the capital
expenditure be approved yeah
points of older chairman it's councillor
rory shaw in the constitution
it says the votes can be done by a
majority
i'm being advised differently councillor
mrs shaw oh i'm just reading the
constitution
that's a 4.15 thank you
17.1 page 4.15 17.1
members we will be taking the
recommendations separately i've read out
recommendation too
those members who wish to have a
recorded vote for recommendation too
would they please
indicate by raising their raised hand
icon please chairman i would like
no recorded vote thank you councillor i
own him
okay so we will then record it chairman
there's no recording
members there'd be no recorded vote
um uh could i ask those police and
for members who are in favor of the
recommendation to raise their
hand icon please
chairman i would like to in favor of the
vote counselor george
thank you councillor i owe you
so i'm just going to council hazelwood
is raising a physical hand chairman
thank you council hazelwood
that's all i can do because my race time
won't work
as i'm putting my hands up like that
thank you council hazelwood we've noted
your vote
the whole person that they're not
members if you could put your race hand
icon down please
and if i could ask those members to vote
against
the recommendation to raise their right
a hand icon please
members if you could take down your race
hand icon please
and those members wishing to abstain
indicate please
members that recommendation has been
passed 27
votes four five against and one
abstentions thank you
members i now take uh recommendation
three
that the assistant director resources be
authorized to adjust capital project
budgets to
in 2021 stroke 22
after the 2020 strokes 21 accounts are
closed and the amount of slippage and
budget
carry forward required are confirmed
with those please who wish a recorded
vote please indicate
by raised hand icon
i don't want to raise a recorded vote
councillor george manning thank you
okay members there will be no recorded
vote please
those who wish to vote for
the recommendation please indicate now
please
chairman i would like to vote for
councillor george irano
councillor heiserwood has his hand
raised
he's just to record my vote because i
can't raise the harness or
thank you councillor hazelwood note your
vote
they can put their hands back down
members if you could um
put your hands down please and those
indicating uh
they wish to vote against them
if you could lower your hands please
members
those who wish to vote against the
recommendation please indicate
chairman we've got two councillors who
are not on
the council at the moment that's uh
craig canel and tony carter
they're trying to get back in
okay that's that's um
counselor do you wish to vote for
against recommendation three
thank you for coming to me chair uh
abstain from item three thank you
abstain yes
recommendation 3 has been approved 27
4 5 against one abstention thank you
members we shall now take recommendation
five
that the 2021 stroke 22 band the
equivalent tank space for the purpose of
determining the council tax charge be
agreed
as 32 051.9
properties those wishing to have a
recorded vote please indicate
members there'll be no recorded vote
those who wish to
vote for please indicate
chairman councillor george iwan i'd like
to vote for
for the motion
thank you council award council
hazelwood
can you put a thumbs up for a vote yes
thank you
members if you could take your hands
down no now please
those wishing to vote against please
indicate
oh wait ch
chairman you do need to wait for the all
hands to go down please
right okay hold on
there who's that right okay so um
thank you members if you could lower
your hands and those
people who wish to abstain please
indicate
members that's been passed thirty four
two against and one abstentions thank
you members
members shall now take item seven
sorry recommendation seven that the
schedule of fees and charges for 2021
stroke 22
set out an appendix to be approved those
wish
to have a recorded vote please indicate
members there will not be a recorded
vote those
members wishing to vote for the
recommendation please indicate
chairman councillor george roma i'd like
to vote for
the recommendation
thank you councillor council hazelwood
can you put a thumbs up please if you
wish to vote
for thank you council hazelwood
ethnicity lifestyle factors
yes
yes
is
members if you could um lower your
raised hand icon thank you
members those wishing to vote against
recommendation seven please indicate
one two three four five
all right okay if they'd like to take
the handstand any any left
members if you could put your hands down
please
members those wishing to abstain please
indicate
okay
members that recommendation has been
passed 27 votes four
six against one abstention
members i shall now take a
recommendation eight
which is that the target general balance
as in the first of april 2021 be set at
one million pounds those
wishing to have a recorded vote please
indicate
chairman excuse me i've i've got uh an
issue at home
uh i have to leave the meeting if you
don't mind
it's councillor wilson thank you
councillor wilson
thank you let me know best of luck with
your issue
so um
remember there's no be no recorded vote
those wishing to
uh vote for the recommendation please
indicate
chairman council george warner i'd like
to vote for for the recommendation
thank you council hazelwood your vote
has been noted
chairman council stanley speaking um my
internet keeps on dropping out so i'm
gonna have to leave the meeting at the
moment
thank you council stanley
members please lower your hands if you'd
be so kind
members those wishing to vote against
the recommendation please indicate
members if you could lower your hand
icon please
and those members wishing to abstain
please indicate
members that's recommendation has been
agreed 28 votes for
none against and four abstentions
members we shall now take our
recommendation 12
that the capital and treasury management
strategy for 2021 stroke 22 was set out
in appendix
3 including the 2021 stroke 22
prudential indicators be agreed
those wishing to have a recorded vote
please indicate
members there will be no recorded vote
please
indicate if you wish to vote in favor
for the recommendation please
chairman councillor george wanna like to
vote in favor of the recommendation
thank you councillor ionu council
hazelwood
thank you for your thumbs up thank you
members if you could lower your hands
for me please
members if you those votes wishing to
vote against
the recommendation please indicate
your hand is up was that meant
members those members wishing to abstain
please indicate
members that recommendation has been
passed 30 votes for
none against and one abstention
members that completes the business of
the uh council
i thank you for your patience and
forbearing
and i close the meeting at 22 15.
thank you chairman good night
chairman thank you thank you for your
contribution